[Music]
it's like kind of magical and again
surreal to have everybody be present
uh and in a space together
[Music]
well it's my first little sort of like
foray into performing my own music live
which is crazy take it from dove cameron
she missed being on stage and that's
exactly where e.t caught up with the 25
year old at the la stop of an evening
with dove cameron concert we were gonna
start doing
like little tours like this
obviously right before the pandemic um
so it's wild it's wild to like have a
body of work
that spans over two years but then to
just be beginning to perform it now
feels very like it feels a little
surreal but it's like so exciting to get
to
sing it with fans who know all the words
and feel the energy every night it's
like a totally new
kind of experience for me which at this
point in my career there aren't that
many of those so it's been amazing
[Music]
something else new her single lazy baby
something old the treasured keepsake she
brings on tour kristen chenoweth
when i was 17
gave me a necklace a bit like a heavy
weighted gold necklace that's like just
on like a dog tag chain
but it's in the shape of a little like
pick
and it says the wise avoid the wicked
and i'm a huge wicked fan um and i love
kristen and she was my idol since i was
teeny tiny and so i take it with me
almost as like she's like this is
protective and i'm like okay
i believe you she's imbued it with magic
and so then therefore it has magic so
i've been taking that with me but is
there a chance for dove to recreate that
magic as christian's character glinda in
the upcoming wicked movie oh my god i
would love to do it i'd love to do it i
mean i think every girl
every girl on the face of the planet
would love to be a part of wicked um
yeah i know they're making it i know
they're finally making it
that's all i know i wish i could tell
you
obviously
oh my god yeah the dream role dream for
now dove is busy with a few other acting
projects including the powerpuff girls
live action series which hit pause after
the cw decided to rework the script
we still are
waiting on the new draft of the script i
know that they're busy in the writers
room i know that they're really happy
with what they're creating
um
you know i think also another
misconception is that actors really know
a lot about what's going on we don't
know anything
it's basically me like every other week
texting my agents being like
what's up with that they're like don't
know and we're like all right i'm gonna
go do this while we wait like
in the meantime dove is heading into
songwriting camps for what she's hoping
to be her debut ep it's really wild
because music has been on pause in the
pandemic essentially and so i've just
been sort of like
you know doing my whole acting gig doing
my whole thing and now
that i've started doing this i'm like oh
you know i started on disney 10 years
ago
that feels crazy and
disney is such a fan
oriented platform
that i think people think
i interact with fans all the time but i
am so much more of like a straight-up
actor like i'm in my sweats all day
i read scripts i'm a homebody i'm very
internal i write poetry i have three
friends i don't you know i'm not like on
the road doing the whole
um performer thing really and and i'm
also really shy and introverted and i
get overwhelmed and i get anxious and
i think people have this idea of me that
really isn't accurate and so
so this is kind of my first time being
this close to what
i didn't even realize i had
in the fan base and it's been really
kind of overwhelming and
um moving so moving so moving to me
and now i'm just kind of like oh
well i want to do this forever
[Music]